[Music]
most little girls wish they will grow up
to become princesses and fall in love
with their prince charming but we think
that we can expect much better from them
we want them to live happily ever after
on their own and be the heroes of their
own stories you'll have to watch this
video until the end to know which Disney
Princess they should admire the most if
you love Disney Princesses as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 Disney Princesses
ranks from worst to best role models for
kids Aurora Aurora is officially the
worst role model any kid could ever have
the princess actually has only 18 lines
of dialogue throughout the entire film
and only appears for 18 minutes she
first speaks 19 minutes into the film
and says her last line 39 minutes in and
during this time the only thing she does
is being protected by the fairies and
falling in love with a stranger that she
walked with once upon a dream
she might be singing two songs but all
she does is wait for her dreams to come
true and fall for a man that she met in
the forest for the rest of the film she
will just be sleeping and patiently
waiting for her prince charming to save
her she is not responsible for this but
Sleeping Beauty is still teaching kids
that all you need to do to live happily
ever after is being pretty and able to
sing that's really the two gifts that
the fairies wanted to give her it's even
better when a woman can't talk and we
are actually shocked that Disney turned
this kiss into something romantic if the
princess couldn't say yes she couldn't
say no it means that she couldn't
consent at the time and this kiss of
true love is actually really
inappropriate Aurora is probably the
last Disney princess little girl should
ever dream of being Cinderella this
Disney Princess inspired many
rags-to-riches stories when her father
passed away she was forced to work as a
servants for her evil stepmother and her
two stepsisters we can't say that she
could have simply run away or told the
authorities leaving everything you ever
knew while people make you think that
you deserve nothing more than that is
incredibly hard to do but we still think
that it's ridiculous to teach young
girls that the only thing they can do is
wait for their fairy godmother to save
them look a little bit of magic Disney
makes us think that the best thing that
could ever happen to Cinderella is to
find the prince that will fall in love
with her so they will have the chance to
live happily ever after he is not so
charming after all when you think that
he can't remember her face and has to
find the girl who can fit in the shoe
and it is just weird that he organizes a
ball to find the suitable wife you
should never trust a guy he wants plenty
of girls at his feet if there is one
thing that we should teach little girls
it's that they should be the heroes of
their own story instead of waiting for
their prince to save them if you want to
escape a terrible family ask for the
help of a social worker not a
good-looking guy Ariel The Little
Mermaid was like most of us when we were
teenagers we were passionate about
something and we wanted to escape the
world that we lived in we also have to
admit that we easily fell in love with
one of the first guys that we saw this
is totally normal but what we don't like
about the Little Mermaid is that area
tried to make her dream come true in the
worst way possible
she changed who she was to please a man
that she didn't even know being a
mermaid is what made her unique and she
decided to sacrifice this and leave
everything behind because she thought
that she would be able to find true love
in three days it's even worse when you
think that a teenager exchanged her
voice for a pair of legs
this was Disney's way to tell us what
you look like is more important than
what you say and it's even better when a
woman just can't talk a love story is
not possible without any form of
communication we knew that she could
write and it would have been a nice way
to tell Erik what was happening but she
just waited patiently hoping that her
prince would suddenly fall in love with
her in the original tale the story ended
in a tragedy
and this is what should have happened in
the Little Mermaid for once we can say
that Ariel should have listened to her
father Snow White she is the oldest but
also the youngest Disney Princess that's
because Snow White was the first Disney
princess ever featured in the movie but
also the youngest one she was only 14
when she fell in love with the prince
and got married which we think is way
too young but let's get back to the
beginning of the story
the young girl wished for the ones she
loved to come in hi
on that day the princess who worked as a
servant was known as the most beautiful
girl in the kingdom and when she escaped
the jealous evil queen what saved her
was being able to clean the house and
cook food like a good housewife for the
little Dwarfs once again we're not
saying that she was responsible for that
but we wish Disney could have added a
little something more to her personality
just like what we saw in Sleeping Beauty
the princess met her prince charming
when she was singing before falling
asleep and both of them were saved by a
kiss of true love once again she
couldn't consent to that kiss as she
wasn't alive anymore and it should take
much more than that
to marry someone you don't owe a man
anything even if he saves your life a
woman or actually a teenager is not
something that you earn if we have one
good thing to say about this story it's
that Snow White did try to help herself
when she escaped her stepmother Belle
it's in Beauty and the Beast that we
finally got the chance to see a young
woman that was not like any other she
was still ready to be a good housewife
and she did all the chores in the house
to help her father but she did have a
little something special though is not
like any other as she loved reading
books and was proud of being smart this
is also the reason why most people
thought that she was weird
she also had ambitions and rejected
Gaston who was supposed to be the most
handsome man in the village
unfortunately things turned out to be
completely wrong when she met the Beast
we do admire that she wanted to save her
father but we don't appreciate how she
fell in love with a man while she was in
an abusive relationship you should never
trust someone who becomes aggressive
when you don't listen to what they say
who walks you into a castle he might
give her anything she wants but this is
something that no one should ever
forgive bow was not responsible for this
and she did the best she could do but
Disney was wrong to make kids believe
that it was romantic when you meet a man
like that don't believe that you will be
able to change them just run away
Rapunzel with some modern-day princesses
we finally had the chance to meet
characters who were starting to be good
role models
this time Rapunzel was trapped in a life
where she had to stay at home to cook
and clean the house as any good
housewife would do but at least this
time she wanted to escape this life and
the best way to do it
this girl loves painting to imagine
herself in a new world and she loved to
learn new things once again she had to
be saved by a prince to have the courage
to run away but at least we appreciate
that she didn't trust him when he
entered her room she even used a frying
pan to defend herself which was a way
for her to re-appropriate a symbol of
feminine oppression and Flynn Rider is
not the only one who saved his Princess
Rapunzel saved him too
she might be too dependent and can't be
left alone but we understand us when we
think about the way she used to live at
least she's not shy to be yourself and
she even knows how to fight with her
hair
Rapunzel is the perfect example of a
girl who doesn't want to be a good girl
anymore
and gets out of her comfort zone to
learn how to be yourself and find love
Jasmine Disney hasn't always been wrong
with the classic princesses jasmine was
actually a great role model the princess
wasn't happy to live in her palace even
if her father just wanted to protect her
this is why she escaped and tried to
discover a whole new world it didn't
really work as she knew nothing about it
but at least she tried her father also
wanted her to find a suitable husband
and Jasmine was not interested in this
at all she just wanted to be happy on
her own and didn't want her father to
have any control over her life even when
she met Aladdin she didn't care about
him she wanted to find a man that she
loved not another random guy he was
going to impress her with his wealth as
if it was a competition
Jasmine even clearly said that she was
not a prize to be won
you'd go girl but just because she was
independent didn't mean that she
couldn't fall in love with someone and
Aladdin is the one who gave her the
chance to escape her palace she didn't
really know how to fight when Jafar
tried to force her to marry him but at
least she knew how to talk to a Ladin
when she didn't like what he did she
even asked her father to change the laws
in Agrabah because she didn't like the
tradition this princess was not perfect
but it was at least a good step forward
Tiana
when we heard that Disney was working on
The Princess and the Frog we were a
little bit disappointed to see that we
were going to see a girl kissing a frog
but then we were really happy to see
that Tiana thought that it was weird too
and she was not even a princess the hero
of this story was a hard-working woman
who had ambitions the most important man
in her
life was her father and she wanted to
pay homage to him by making their dream
come true she wanted to start her own
restaurant and she was ready to do
anything to do this including kissing a
frog who said that he would give her
money in exchange Tiana was not a
princess so she turned into a frog too
this was when her journey started and
hope to become human again she did have
her friends who was really just like the
stereotypical girly princess but at
least we saw a nice diversity of female
characters so if you wanted to be a
princess you could admire Charlotte and
if he wanted to be a strong independent
woman you could look up to Tiana
she still ended up with the prince at
the end just like all the other
princesses before her but we can forgive
this we can still say that Tiana is part
of the top role models Merida and here
comes a princess that was not like any
other this time Merida was not
interested in men at all and she is the
first one who didn't change her mind at
the end of the movie but that didn't
keep her parents from telling her that
she had to mirror the oldest son of one
of their allies they even had to compete
to find out who was the perfect husband
this was when Merida decided that she
was going to compete for her own hand
she wanted to be the only one who has
control over her life as she didn't want
to belong to anyone and she won after
that most of the story focused on the
princess who had to make sure that her
mother wouldn't stay a bear forever and
we'd like to see that the love of her
family is the only thing that should
matter at that age Merida finally agreed
to find a husband even though she was
not really interested in that this was
when her mother decided that she should
have the right to marry whoever she
wants whenever she wants and we are
pretty sure that it won't be anytime
soon this is how Disney finally taught
kids like you don't have to break the
rules when you can simply talk to your
parents and no young woman should ever
need a man but who is the number one on
our list Elsa this Disney character is
not only a princess she is actually a
queen and she doesn't need any king in
her life it doesn't mean that she is
perfect it was hard for Elsa to control
her power and this is why she decided to
stay away from her family but when she
finally understood that this unique
trait was making her powerful and that
she could even help others with it she
was stronger than ever
we all remember the song let it go and
catch singing it for months because
was so inspiring the only thing Elsa
needed was the love of her sister to
warm her heart and she was ready to take
care of those who lived in her kingdom
and she is also the one who had the best
line in every Disney movie you can't
marry a man you just met while Anna
learns that you have to get to know
someone before falling in love with them
Elsa proved that women don't even need
men in their life and this is what makes
her the greatest role model on the list
but we have to admit that Moana is
awesome too so we'll have to make them
both number one on our list is there any
other Disney princess that you would
like to add to this list don't be shy to
tell us who it is in the comment section
down below and that's it for 10 Disney
Princesses ranks from worst to best role
models for kids for more stories like
this make sure you watch 10 strange
requirements to work as a Disney
Princess thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]